[Music]  hello hello boys  nice try Eric yep nothing Eric okay  who is this I like the way you decorated  the place by the way I'm looking at my  door no one's at my door yeah okey-dokey  hello what do you want  I like your black shirt I'm wearing I'm  not wearing a black shirt I'm wearing a  grey shirt no I don't know but it's not  me is he waving no I'm waving you're on  CBS right T and we're good TBS yeah no  it's a nightmare I'm your worst  nightmare Pete okay bye then  [Music]  what are you doing this is Kurt he took  away my knife oh they didn't let you on  the one with a clown mask and a knife no  that's weird  do you want to look around my office for  something to kill me with sure  what is that it's blunt-force trauma to  your temple yeah I good at this sorry  I'm sorry  [Music]